in diesem jahr ist die letzte berlinale
unter der ägide von dieter kosslick der
ja vor allen dingen im letzten jahr
erhebliche kritik einstecken musste
ich fand das ganze nicht so gerecht er
hat wie ich finde eine ganze menge
erreicht vor allen dingen fürs kino
offizielle eröffnungsfilm ist ein film
der den in dohna schöpflin bekenntnis of
strangers und ich kann hier nur sagen
was die regisseurin selbst zugesagte
beziehungsweise was das festival als
inhaltsangabe gibt und das klingt so als
würden viele der probleme die wir
heutzutage haben also wie ist das mit
migration wie ist das wie ist das mit
den rollen wie ist es mit dem
der der kluft zwischen arm und reich
dass all dieses in der freundlichen
schon eines liebes briefes an die stadt
new york verhandelt wird
naturgemäß lässt sich darüber was denn
dann zu sehen sein wird noch überhaupt
nicht sagen außer dass mein namen sagen
kann und zahlen ich finde die zahlen in
diesem jahr interessant die eine zahl in
diesem jahr interessant denn im
vergangenen jahr scheint die berlinale
ja vollständig in der nicht im schatten
aber unter dem thema der mito debatte
und es wurde viel über frauen und ihren
anteil am geschäft und an der kunst
diskutiert und in diesem jahr ist es nun
tatsächlich so dass von den 17
wettbewerbs führen jeden von regisseurin
geprägt wurden das ist eine fantastische
zeit finde ich nicht viel versprechende
zahl und ich hoffe natürlich dass auch
die filme entsprechend sein werden
andy schleck hat einen beigen
[Musik]
wollen sehr auf einige andere berlinale
veteranen denn der kosslick hat eine
sache gemacht die schöne und auch glück
finde er hat nämlich offenbar sich
gesagt muss mein letztes festival ich
hole mir die leute die ich quasi auch
groß gemacht habe und die mir war es zu
verdanken haben und ich hoffe da sie in
entsprechend feiern werden dass da eine
große party steigt für den man einen
teil ihrer karriere ermöglicht hat dazu
gehören denis cote et dazu gehört sein
insgesamt aber gucken doch sehr viele
auf fatih akin eine der drei deutschen
filme die im wettbewerb laufen hat vor
15 jahren hier seine karriere angefangen
mit gegen die wand
goldenen bären gleich gewonnen und kommt
jetzt in diesem jahr mit der verfilmung
von normalen der goldenen handschuh bist
du denn
frieden brustdrüse gibt sehr viele leute
die auf diesem film unheimlich neugierig
werden ich sehe dem mit einigem bangen
entgegen muss ich sagen ich das
natürlich auch daran dass frauenmörder
filme nicht so zu meinen allerliebsten
film geben nicht im allerliebsten für
mich gehören
ansonsten finde ich es großartig dass
mit diesem letzten jahr kosslick in der
retrospektive ein werk korpus sozusagen
betrachtet wird der völlig hinten und
neben runter fällt immer eine
geschichtsschreibung keine große rolle
spielt in den ganzen film erbe
diskussionen keine rolle spielt das sind
filme von filmemacherinnen zwischen 1970
etwa und 1990 und zwar sowohl in dem das
damals berge als auch in der ddr der
sind neue perspektiven das sind
großartige sind auch endlich mal einige
in wirklich außer anderen witzigen
filmen dabei die bilder habe ich immer
so eine ernste schön auf den nie darf
ich es hoffe auch dass mit dieser
retrospektive dieser ganze ganzen
bereich feministischer film kann man
glaube ich so im groben mal sagen und er
ist die mal wieder ins zentrum des
interesses rücken das finde ich ganz
großartig und auch das ist natürlich ein
teil des erbes von kosslick